right next hour on Capitol Hill
Republicans hold their final impeachment
hearing for DHS secretary Alejandra
mayorcas over his handling of the Border
crisis they here firsthand accounts from
Key Witnesses including our next guest
who's written testimony give us a brutal
firsthand account of how bad it is
cooches County Arizona Sheriff Mark
Danielle joins us now Sheriff thanks so
much for joining the program uh what do
we what can we expect from you uh during
this hearing
today
well I've submitted a written testimony
which outlines uh my community my the
reality of what's going on in cooches
County what's going on in the Southwest
border what have sheriffs throughout the
country done to try to make it better if
this is all about Public Safety National
Security and humanitarian and all three
categories Lawrence have have been a
failure failure uh when it comes to
what's going on in Washington DC and the
lack of policies that have worked these
policies aren't working no more you look
at the tragedies you look at the Border
crime that we're dealing with the death
that we're dealing with and just the
quality of life that every Community
expects it's not happening here in uh
cois County with the Pursuits every day
the trespass issues and the thought and
the assaults on law enforcement yeah you
know Sheri there was a point in time
where they would say oh it's just
conservatives that are talking about
these are people that hate immigrants
that are talking about now you got
Charlotte man the god saying that people
are so upset about this uh this is
Charlamagne
watch I honestly have never spoken to as
many people who are concerned about the
migrant issue as I have you know o over
the past year they took 2,000 migrants
and and and put them in the school and
made the school stay home made the the
students stay home and and and and uh
you know do school via via VIA zoom and
that was a big issue like I mean people
were calling the radio station that was
just this week you know really really
really complaining about that so I've
never seen you know working class people
who I interact with every day until this
past year really really really expressed
their frustration sherff you got Urban
America and you know Rural America
saying the same thing
now yeah we gotta get back to Lawrence
where America needs to prioritize NB
first we got to take over our citizens
our veterans our children our elderly
and just American citizens and second of
all he said something I thought was very
telling in that interview was the fact
that uh this Administration loves to
take credit for things that they
perceive or believe are good they also
need to take credit for things that
aren't working to include this border
and put America Community back on the
map of being a priority and take care of
it the top issue for Iowa in this last
caucus was immigration let's see what
happens in New Hampshire Sheriff thanks
so much good luck with your testimony
today we'll be
watching take care bye-bye I'm Steve duy
I'm Brian kilme and I'm Angley aart and
click here to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling
analysis